a classical computer performs operations
using classical bits which can be either
0 or 1 now in contrast a quantum
computer uses quantum bits or qubits and
they can be both 0 and 1 at the same
time and it is this that gives a quantum
computer it's superior computing power
there are a number of physical objects
that can be used as a qubit a single
photon a nucleus or an electron I met up
with researchers who are using the
outermost electron in phosphorus as a
qubit but how does that work well all
electrons have magnetic fields so
they're basically like tiny bar magnets
and this property is called spin if you
place them in a magnetic field they will
align with that field just like a
compass needle lines up with the
magnetic field of the earth now this is
the lowest energy State so you can call
it the zero State or we call it for the
electron spin down now you can put it in
a one state or spin up but that takes
some energy if you took out the glass
from your compass you could turn the
needle the other way but you would have
to apply some force to it you have to
push it to flip to the other side and
that is the highest energy state in
principle if you were so delicate to
really put it exactly against the
magnetic field it would stay there now
so far this is basically just like a
classical bit it's got two states spin
up and spin down would you like the
classical one and zero but the funny
thing about quantum objects is that they
can be in both states at once
now when you measure the spin it will be
either up or down but before you measure
it the electron can exist in what's
called a quantum superposition where
these coefficients indicate the relative
probability of finding the electron in
one state or the other now it's hard to
imagine how this enables the incredible
computing power of quantum computers
without considering two interacting
quantum bits hello hi now there are four
possible states of these two electrons
you could think that well it's just like
two bits of a classical computer right
if you have two bits you can write 0 0 0
1 1 0
one and it's for numbers but these are
still just two bits of information right
all I need to say to determine which one
of the four numbers you have in your
computer code is the value of the first
bit and the value of the secretary here
instead quantum mechanics allows it to
make superposition of each one of these
four states so I can write a quantum
mechanical state which is perfectly
legitimate that is some coefficient
times this plus some coefficient times
that plus some coefficient and that plus
some coefficient so to determine the
state of this two spin system I need to
give you four numbers four coefficients
whereas in the classical example of the
two bits I only need to give you two
bits so this is how you understand why
two qubits actually contain four bits of
information I need to give you four
numbers to tell you the state of the
system whereas here only need two if we
make three spins we would have eight
different states I need to give you
eight different numbers to define the
state of those three spins whereas
classical is just three bits if you keep
going what you'll find is that the
amount of equivalent classical
information contained by n qubits is two
to the power n classical bits and of
course the power of Exponential's tells
you that once you have let's say 300 of
those qubits in what we call the fully
entangled state so you must be able to
create these really crazy states where
there is a superposition of all three
others being one way and another way in
the other way and so on then you have
like two to the three hundred classical
bits which is as many particles as there
are universe but there's a catch
although the qubits can exist in any
combination of states when they are
measured they must fall into one of the
basis states and all the other
information about this
before the measurement is lost so you
don't walk generally to have as the
final result of your quantum computation
something that is a very complicated
superposition of states because you
cannot measure a superposition you can
only measure one of these basis States
so what you want is to design the logic
operations that you need to get to the
final computational result in such a way
that the final result is something
you're able to measure it's just a
unique state there's no trigger and it's
essentially kind of stretching things
there but I guess it's to some degree
the reason why quantum computers are not
a replacement for classical no no
they're not universally faster they're
only faster for special types of
calculations where you can use the fact
that you have all these quantum
superpositions available to you at the
same time to do some kind of
computational parallelism if you just
want to watch a video in height in
high-definition or browse the internet
or write some document in Word they're
not gonna give you any particular rule
if you need to use a classical algorithm
to get yourself so you should not think
of a quantum computer as something where
every operation is faster in fact every
operation is probably gonna be slower
then in the computer you have the desk
but it's an a computer where the number
of operations required to arrive at the
result is exponentially small so the
improvement is not in the speed of the
individual operation is in the total
number of operations you need to arrive
at the result but that is only the case
in particular types of calculations in
particular algorithm is not universally
which is why it's not a replacement of a
classical